bonjour à tous merci beaucoup d'être en
direct ce matin avec nous sur rt france
pour commenter cette actualité
sanitaires alors on l'a vu l'irlande
championne du monde de vaccination
envisage des restrictions au portugal
également où la population est mieux
avec ce n'est qu'en france à paris rien
n'était envisagé à ce stade pourtant on
a largement dépassé le seuil d alerte
est ce que ces responsables selon vous
où gilbert ange rejet
pour l'instant oui je crois que les
efforts qu'il nous faut porter c'est sur
l'été et 5 millions environ de personnes
qui n'ont pas fait la première
vaccination dont ceux là il faut les
amener à se faire berner et puis rappelé
aux personnes plus âgées
[Musique]
de la troisième action sera menée
seulement nécessaire donc il faut là
c'est ce que du gouvernement en tout cas
c'est ce qu'ils voulaient et
voilà ouais c'est ce que nos
gouvernements aux bêtas et c'est pas
parce que je suis dans l'opposition que
je ne vais pas dire qu'ils ne
il faudrait faire autrement il faut
absolument faire ça et moi j'ai apprécié
hier aux questions d'actualité au sénat
la réponse de olivier ferrand le
ministre la santé de nos collègues de
saint martin qui voulait qu'on abandonne
tout pour laisser les îles
faire ce qu'elles veulent c'est des
repas de va-t-il ont pas ne masque pas
de restrictions quand on voit comment ça
s'est passé en guadeloupe à saint martin
saint barth et martinique il ya quelques
mois où il a fallu quand même plus de
médicaux des de l'hexagone
pour aller
un peu soignée aux antilles c'est pas
admissible donc il faut que partout des
efforts qu'ils soient frais alexis
people et on l'a dit un tout le pack
quasiment tous les pays européens
envisagent ou ont imposé de nouvelles
restrictions et on le voit la france
freiner des quatre fers on va écouter
gabriela talk icq s'est exprimé hier et
ce week-end sur cette question de
nouvelles mesures de restriction et je
repose ma question après il n'y a
absolument aucun confinement qui est
prévue aujourd'hui ni de près ni de loin
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de raison de
penser que les fêtes de fin d'année
seront ternie par des jauges comme en
2020 mais il faut que l'immunité
conférée par le vaccin se poursuivent et
donc que les français éligibles face le
rappel de vaccination pourquoi cet
attentisme selon vous est ce que ces
politiques on sait que les élections
approchent
alors je j'ai un peu de mal à
m'expliquer cet attentisme en tout cas
ce que je sais c'est qu'à une
imprévoyance absolument ébouriffante du
goût de ce gouvernement qui est on peut
se demander légitimement ou sont par
exemple les purificateurs d'air dans les
écoles nous ça fait cinq mois qu'on le
demande de la ville de hyères dont
nicolas dupont aignan et le député à
équiper toutes ses écoles de
purificateurs d'air le 9e arrondissement
madame dur kitty en marche à équiper
toutes ses écoles de purificateurs d'air
où sont ils un purificateur d'air 50 500
euros et ça pourrait empêcher les
enfants d'être d'être masqué deuxième
conte comment se fait-il encore une fois
sur cette imprévoyance comment se
fait-il qu'on continue à fermer des lits
d'hôpitaux il y en a cinq mille sept
cent qui ont fermé en 2020 comment se
fait-il que nous ayons que seulement
6200 et de réanimation alors que
monsieur verront des crises parle de
7000 de 10000 ou de 12000 ça changé et
que nous à aînés allemands en ont quinze
mille comment ça se fait au chapitre de
cette imprévoyance qu'on est toujours
aucun traitement qu'on investisse pas
pardon dans les traitements préventifs
c'est le karma défi c'est le cas il ya
un médicament qui a été acheté par le
gouvernement récemment oui ça fait au
bout de 18 mois ont remis les premiers
première évolution vous 18 mois après
avoir balayé d'un revers de main les
médicaments et l'ivermectine hydroxy
coquine je sais pas si ça fonctionne je
suis pas médecin mais je sais que ça
avait été balayé d'un revers de la main
sont plus d'études commencé qu est-ce
que c'est aussi et surtout et ça ça
commence heureusement affaire à monter
dans l'actualité qu'est ce que c'est que
cette idée délirante de caen l'automne
arrive de mettre payant les tests est
grand temps de les remettre gratuit
c'est est donc ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est que y'a un attentisme et on a
toujours un train de retard fait ce
gouvernement a toujours un train de
retard dans la gestion de cette crise et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
arrêtons cette ville atlantiste et
prenons les mesures de bon sens qui
s'imposent pour lutter efficacement
contre cette maladie
alors justement vous parlez du
rétablissement des tests on va écouter
ce que ce qu'en dit le professeur gilles
pialoux il il s'est dit favorable
évidemment au rétablissement des tests
gratuits
bien sûr que le test protègent moins que
le vaccin mais c'est un outil de plus
pour détecter plus tôt pour isoler
quelqu'un qui se sait positif n'a pas le
même comportement c'est une mort il
s'isole il prend des mesures là on va
être dans une situation hivernale où il
va y avoir des gens qui vont en avoir
plein de symptômes qui ressemblent à un
kobe de bénin et ne vont pas se faire
dépister gilbert roger pour vous êtes
une erreur de rendre payant ces tests
tutelle l'erreur suprême pour nous en
particulier le groupe socialiste et de
ne pas avoir rendu la vaccination
obligatoire
nous le faisons sur les vaccins guy
infantile à chaque enfant avant l'entrée
à l'école
maternelle ou avant l'entrée en crèche
je le comprends pas qu'on n'ait pas
retenu cela plutôt d'inciter ou 2,8 et
via le pass sanitaire je comprends
j'entends tout à fait les citoyens
i comme la dame toutes leurs idées quoi
ou mode m'impose de faire le troisième
vaccin où on me retire le pass est par
contre celui ou celle qui ne se
vaccinent pas du tout on lui il paierait
le test ptr tous les jours oh c'est
anormal donc ce qu'il faudrait d'abord
c'est
interdire est
effectivement mettre en place la
vaccination obligatoire la suède elle va
mettre en place un pass vaccinale est
imposée en plus des tests aux personnes
vaccinées ya ce sondage surprenant la
qualité publiés ce matin six français
sur dix veulent confiner les non
vaccinés comme en autriche
quel est votre commentaire
je suis à l'est pour le sénat au
portugal où on nous a demandé d'avoir un
test pcr moins 72 heures avant de
prendre l'avion bon c'est pas choquant
on le fait et il faut avoir et nos tests
pcr et la vaccination et je pense que si
tout cela est fait pour nous protéger
collectivement alors faut pas hésiter
alexis vite les réactions non ou alors
nous on est totalement opposé à ce
vaccin obligatoire et premier plan
non n'est pas laisser le jeu vous permet
pas de dire ça monsieur monsieur vous où
sont les idéaux du socialiste de liberté
là il y en a plus et fondis la liberté
et le vaccin obligatoire c'est
absolument n'importe quoi monsieur leur
action collective non mais c'est pas y'a
pas y'a pas couvert par
à 10 ans c'est assez compliqué de de
s'invectiver
le vaccin juste voix pour lire ses les
choses quel moment pour nous
vaccin il faut aller voir son médecin
traitant qui connaît mieux le patient
l'état de santé du patient que le
médecin traitant ça devrait on devrait
redonner le pouvoir le pouvoir
le haut conseil aux médecins traitants
c'est pas monsieur untel ou monsieur
macron ils sont pas médecins que je
sache il faudrait que ce soit pour nous
ça devrait être le médecin traitant qui
en fonction de l'état de son patient dit
oui ou non il faut se vacciner deuxième
point on a un il ya une notion de
bénéfices risques pour les gens âgés ou
en comorbidités oui on peut imaginer que
le vaccin serait une bonne chose en
revanche pour les gens qui n'ont aucun
risque on peut légitimement penser que
le vaccin n'est pas extrêmement utile et
les gens âgés qui seront vaccinés comme
ça ils ne risquent rien ne risque pas
d'être contaminé par les gens non
vaccinés on est quand même dans une
situation ubuesque où on va avoir les
vous lisiez monsieur tout à l'heure les
plus de 85 ans il ya 15 % des plus de 85
ans qui ne sont pas vaccinés on va voir
une situation ubuesque bientôt où on
aura plus de jeu en 2 12 18 ans qui
seront vaccinées que john plus de 85 ans
il faut d'urgence aller chercher avec
des camions dans les villages les jambes
plus de quatre ans à contre les inciter
pour les encourager à se vacciner mais
pourquoi aller vacciner des plus de 15
ans ça n'a absolument pas de sens donc
nous notre point de vue c'est évidemment
pas de vaccination obligatoire en plus
en parallèle sur la question du pass
sanitaires le pass le vaccin ne protège
protège un petit paumé pas totalement
loin de là de la transmission on voit
bien les relents de pays le plus
vacciner alors plus fort taux de
contamination aujourd'hui en europe bien
sûr le gouvernement nous ont raconté des
farces le gouvernement nous disait que
le vaccin si vous étiez vaccinez vous
aviez tout soit moins de chances
d'attraper le coc vive excès ou dix fois
au ch'ti fois en réalité il y avait une
étude assez intéressant du ministère de
la santé israélien qui expliquait avoir
fait son vaccin réduisez la transmission
de 39% c'est mieux que rien 39% mais
c'est pas si fois une fois dit soi ou de
soi ça n'a absolument rien à voir donc
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
tout misé sur le pass annie terre et non
seulement
contraignant pour nos libertés
individuelles mais en plus ce n'est pas
extrêmement efficace parce que là qu'est
ce qui se passe les gens qui sont
vaccinés et je pense que c'est ce qu'on
voulait dire aussi monsieur pialoux les
gens qui sont ainsi nés ils se testent
plus maintenant puisqu'ils ont là ils
ont le sentiment d'être taxés que tout
va bien alors même ils peuvent attraper
le coc vide grâce au vaccin il faut le
reconnaître ils ont peut-être pas de cas
graves dont ils sont ils sont pas
vraiment malade mais ils peuvent le
transmettre donc il faut d'urgence
rétablir comme on le disait des tests
gratuits et retrouver une politique de
bon sens où la vaccination est basé sur
l'avis du médecin traitant ça paraît pas
délirant et contrairement ce que vous
dire monsieur c'est pas complotistes que
de dire appuyons sur l'axé entre aidants
j'ai plutôt le sentiment que c'est du
bon sens alors on va parler de du
travail du télétravail qui est
réinstauré aussi dans dans beaucoup de
pays européens elisabeth bornes alico
pour l'instant ce n'était pas
d'actualité
faudrait-il rétablir en tout cas le
télétravail selon vous gilbert roger
oui
moi je compte lui est très fort
télétravail est il et on regarde bien il
se pratique il continue de se pratiquer
ces
méthodes
de productivité pense que nous avons
effectivement découvert et qui se
poursuit donc il faut continuer
là-dessus doit dire à
monsieur interlocuteur d'été coque pour
liot quand on vaccine les enfants il ya
quasiment plus polio en france le regard
n'a encore un peu donc c'est pas parce
qu'il y en a un peu qu'il faut dire que
le vaccin le fond ne s'est elle pas par
rapport aux millions d'enfants qui sont
vos vaccins pas du même garçon avait osé
monsieur josé comparé la situation de la
polio et duco vide est folle où il ya
beaucoup de collègues c'est ridicule non
mais
on connaît les on connaît la vie des
gens locaux lui le commis dans des
extrêmement malade le pot vide l'on est
quelque chose moi j'en ai dans ma fait
je vois les gens qui ont fait 2 mois de
de coma et qui sont désormais dans des
grandes fatigues alors oui il faut se
protéger ils te les trappeurs une façon
aussi de se protéger tout en continuant
de produire et de l'avoir l'activité
économique dynamique alors est-ce qu'il
faut pas uniquement finalement protéger
les personnes fragiles vacciner les
personnes fragiles sachant que le vous
disiez le vaccin empêche les formes
graves mais n'empêche pas la
transmission
vous savez que vous n'êtes pas un jules
madame vous êtes peut-être en bonne
santé aujourd'hui on soutient enfants
par exemple sont par les jeux ne sont
pas mais parce que pour la on a
peut-être pas assez de recul
scientifique
sur le fait de vacciner ou de ne pas
vacciner les enfants l'étude américaine
vient d'être menée et qui
recommande la vaccination
parce qu'avant tout des résultats aux
etats-unis nous avions par an et qui
fait qu'israël va commencer les
vaccinations elle et on peut précise
faut continuer et bien que les
scientifiques
examine je la vois pas de dubois
l'économie bruno le maire lui s'est
montré le ministre de l'économie s'est
exprimé également sur ce sujet de la
burqa du regard pandémie qu'elle s'est
montrée aussi optimiste écoutez le
nous devons tout faire pour éviter de
nous retrouver dans une situation où
nous étions l'année dernière en tant que
ministre de l'économie je n'ai qu'une
envie que les commerçants puissent
ouvrir que les restaurants puis s'être
plaint pendant les périodes de fêtes
j'ai envie que ça tourne pour les
français que ça marche alexis villepelet
ce volontarisme sais je répète ma
question du début est ce que c'est une
un discours justement pour mon c'est
qu'on ne veut absolument pas confiné
parce que ça peut être un risque pour
une éventuelle élection d' emmanuel
macron alors il ya deux choses premier
point le volontarisme l'ambition c'est
toujours une bonne chose mais il faut
faire les choses intelligemment on a un
gouvernement qui d'une part est toujours
important c'est ce que je disais en
début d'émission une forme d'un
prévoyant sur les thèses lits d'hôpitaux
et qui d'autre a tendance à affoler les
gens n'ont pas bruno le maire mais les
autres ont tendance à affoler les gens
donc un moment il faut avoir faire une
politique de bon sens comme je le disais
tout à l'heure en mettant des puristes
cadre des ronds rétablissant la gratuité
des tests ne sont pour autant affoler
les gens comme semblent le fait comme
semble parfois le faire certains membres
du gouvernement donc
oui surtout les scientifiques après
prem's et clé il faut que le
gouvernement que les gouvernements
fassent leur travail qu'ils ne soient ce
ne seront n'a pas éludé scientifique n'a
pas éludé scientifique à la tête de la
france il n'y a pas un conseiller
scientifique il prend le pouvoir il ya
des hommes politiques qui qui et analyse
les qui pèsent le tour et le conte qu'il
ya des données des aspects social dans
cette question et il serait grand temps
de il serait grand donc voilà mais le
jour là pour le coup je vais plutôt
donné un satisfecit au gouvernement j'ai
tendance à penser que leur politique a
repris le dessus depuis quelques mois
sur le tout scientifique mais monsieur
le dîner je suis pas dans des accords
intégrale avec monsieur le télétravail
c'est aussi une
façon d'avoir une
des actions intelligentes ça c'est cette
maladie sachant bien sûr que l'était le
travail tout le monde ne peut pas en
faire sur les chaînes industrielles on
ne peut pas forcément faire duper de
travail mais c'est pas d'actualité
encore la dirige avait deux bornes ce
week-end gilbert roger en parlant de la
déclaration de bruno le maire il faut
tout faire pour éviter la situation l'an
dernier on a vu hier les chiffres de la
cci sur la vacance des commerçants à
paris de
signer folin et à produire des livres la
halle il en est à son quatrième roman à
lorient le même l'économie et donc
monsieur le maire devrait remettre sans
pourtant
au service des petits artisans et les
commerçants
voilà
un commentaire sur ce chiffre de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie sur
la vacance des commerçants à paris au
premier semestre 13 % de commerces ont
fermé avenue de l'opéra par exemple 15%
rue de rivoli 20% sur le boulevard saint
michel j'imagine que c'est le cas
également en france mais n'y a pas
d'études poussées encore à ce stade
qu'en pensez vous cocoon donnent tous
ces commerces qui ont fermé
[Musique]
alors
regarder un commerce n'était pas entre
guillemets bien important avant la
période peu vide la deuxième chose et
pas trop souvent c'est que dans beaucoup
de villes et paris en élections le prix
au mètre carré de loyers
exorbitants et les rues vous avez cité
dans paris intra muros
il faut faire un chiffre d'affaires
extraordinaire pour payer les loyers
donc il faut peut-être aussi revenir à
raison garder
et puis troisième volet mais c'est là on
en attend ce gouvernement qui
malheureusement n'est pas très ambitieux
il n'y a pas une véritable politique des
signaux simple et clair pour pouvoir
reprendre un commerce s'installer
durablement dans les villes les villages
où les grandes villes voilà ça ça mange
alors dernière question avec si vous ne
peut aller on parlait de cette crise
sanitaire sera t-elle fatale ou pas pour
emmanuel macron que pensez vous de cette
crise qui a quand même été au menu de la
moitié du quinquennat d'emmanuel macro
est ce que ça a servi le président de la
république ou est-ce que ça l'a desservi
selon vous alors c'est un gain grand
paradoxe il faut souligner c'est que
il ya quand même eu 120 mille morts de
ce que vides en france et et une gestion
absolument calamiteuse en début de crise
qui aurait dû pu est peut-être dû valoir
la démission d'au moins quelques
ministres dont celui de la santé
qu'est ce qu'on voit en fin de course on
voit il s'est assis c'est bien souligné
par vaux par les journalistes et par vos
collègues monsieur macron
surf sur son soi disant bon bilan
sanitaire est manifestement ce sera un
atout selon les gens laissent pour être
élu mais en réalité il faut dire la
vérité quand on voit le nom de mort qu'a
eue quand on sait qu'elle de confinement
et demi quand on sait qu'à 350 milliards
d'euros qui ont été dépensés pour cette
crise quand on sait que 35% des jeunes
ont des pensées suicidaires
quand on sait que l'apprentissage pour
les plus petits a été a été grandement
affecté par cette crise dans le par le
port du mas on peut pas dire que c'est
un bon mélange donc à un moment il
faudrait être réaliste monsieur macron
va très paradoxalement essayer de
s'appuyer sur cette pseudo bonne gestion
de la crise sa gestion de la crise a été
calamiteuse la france s'est effondré en
2020 la croissance française le pib
français s'est effondré et en 2021 on a
bruno le maire monsieur avait raison il
ferait mieux de travailler plutôt que
d'écrire des bouquins elles le pib est
en train de se redresser et on
communique là dessus mais si on a plus
6% cyan la plus que les autres c'est con
c'était beaucoup plus elles fondre et
avant c'est évident donc il faut arrêter
de dire des bêtises chizé par ailleurs
que le gouvernement se gargarise du
pseudo plein emploi
avant sous chirac sarkozy mitterrand
aussi regarder ou regarder les sites du
chômage celui des demandeurs d'emploi en
fin de mois celui des inscrits à pôle
emploi je peux vous dire que quand vous
regardez les chiffres de pôle emploi
c'est la gym donner vos depuis 2007 ya
aucune aucune baisse du chômage et il
n'y a aucune baisse du nombre de
demandeurs d'inscrits au total on reste
à 6 5 millions d'inscrits donc quand
j'entends ce gouvernement se gargarise
est pareillement poids ça me fait rire
doucement alors aujourd'hui avait réagi
sur une dernière image pour vous j'ai
une belle roger en parler de la
guadeloupe tout à l'heure on demande aux
français de garder les les les gestes
barrière de garder le masque de
l'imposer dans les écoles et pourtant
les politiques font le contraire jean
castex à la mf qui serrait des mains
avec des maires qui ne portait pas de
masque vous voyez sur cette image et
puis ce tweet de florian philippot qui
est le représentant des anticipations
précise regarder
non pour la part tant pis voilà une
réaction à florian philippot s'indigner
du fait que sébastien lecornu et
participer à un apéro clandestins en
nouvelle calédonie en plein confinement
réaction sans droit d'aller écouter et
un ministre doit pouvoir contenu
sérieux à fo que comme tout le monde
comme les sénateurs nous le ferons nous
prenons
élisapie couplet est barrière mais il y
a un certain nombre d'endroits où
lorsque vous rentrez vous devez
présenter votre pass sanitaires et e
mais si on est dans une salle
où on sait que tout le monde et on
disait que le port du masque reste quand
même obligatoire parce que la
transmission frau pourrait comme quand
même se faire donc
je suis d'accord mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il ya bien un certain
nombre d'endroits
on est contrôlé par se passer une fois
qu on a été contrôlé au monde lise houle
pas donc on peut peut-être se parlait
parfois sans et lorsque ces eaux castex
vient au sénat il a sont assez
obligatoire d'accord merci beaucoup en
tout cas c'était là à l'image du second
merci merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat en direct sur rt
france